CHRIS MESSINA: Hello,
everybody.
My name is Chris Messina.
I am a UX designer on the
Google+ platform team.
I'm joined by Paul Lindner
who is a tech lead on
the platform team.
For those of you who don't know,
Paul is very famous.
He's a co inventor of Gopher.
And for you youngsters in the
room, I will spare you the
task of looking up.
It was very, very,
very important.
So you should all be very
impressed with the stuff that
Paul's going to tell
you today.
Also for those of you who are
here in the room today
wondering why my hair's not dark
and why I'm not a little
shorter, because I am not
Chris Messina the actor.
So I can sign autographs,
but it's not
going to be worth anything.
So if that's the guy you're
looking for you can
quietly exit now.
I won't be offended.
Happens all the time, in some
ways because of the things
that we're going to talk
to you about today.
So as you guys probably know,
Google is all about getting
the right content to the right
people at the right time in
the right place and with all
the right context and all
these things.
We also care deeply
about publishers.
We care about the content
that you create.
We care about your ability to
get that content to people who
are interested in
that content.
We think about all
the time that you
put into that content.
And we always are thinking about
new ways of actually
introducing that stuff to people
when they are most open
to and interested
in seeing it.
In a sense, you could think of
us as a content matchmaker.
But we're at an interesting
crossroads.
There's a problem.
The way that people get,
consume, interact with and ask
for information is changing.
People's behaviors
are changing.
There are new types of devices
coming out all the time.
We've seen that.
So we need to work together
Google, publishers, people who
put things on the web, people
who create things for the
internet, people who create
apps, to solve what I think is
going to be an increasingly
interesting and very, very
challenging problem for all of
us in order to create better
content experiences
for people.
In other words, what worked in
1998 when Google got its
start, essentially mapping
the web, mapping all the
relationships sort of like the
original latent fuzzy social
network that was out there.
That doesn't really work
that well anymore.
It works pretty well for us, and
it works pretty well sort
of in general.
But I think increasingly the
way that people ask for
information is becoming
less specific.
People are constantly
interacting with computing
devices that don't have
keyboards, so they're asking
for things without as much
context, or without as many
words as they used to look at.
We know that, for example, query
lengths are actually
becoming shorter and smaller
because people are doing more
and more searches on their
mobile phones.
So given all that context and
given that behavior change,
how do we still deliver content
to people with less
information coming from people
about their requests?
In other words, before, we used
to be able to look at
those input strings that people
would type into Google
and then make a bunch of
assumptions both about the
input as well as about your
content to make those
connections come together.
But now that there's so much
content on the web, now
there's so much information out
there, we need to start
becoming more precise.
This is actually one of the
reasons why Google+ exists.
Google previously didn't have
a very strong notion of a
person, nor of a person and
their relationships.
We were able to extract
different types of information
from different contexts.
But we actually needed more help
from people to tell us
who were the most important
people to them in terms of
people in their photos, the
people they send messages to,
the people that they
interact with and
put into their circles.
This is very, very important
information that allows us to
create better experiences for
people that create deeper
lasting relationships.
We also need more context about
the things that people
are interacting with
in the world.
And we need more context
about the
content that you're producing.
So as a designer, this is what's
really exciting to me
about where the web is going.
With things like schema.org, all
the different markup that
we're able to put out there
with the moments API and a
bunch of stuff that Paul's going
to talk about, we're
able to get much more precise
to deliver much better
experiences to people.
And some of those experiences
include the new Maps that you
saw today, where you're able to
search for things like show
me things near where I am now
and it makes assumptions and
is able to deliver very precise
solutions to you.
Things like self-driving cars.
We know so much about the
world because of the
structured data that a lot of
companies have been producing
over the last couple years.
With things like Now and
anticipatory search, we're
able to deliver stuff to
people before they
know they need it.
And we're able to deliver things
with interfaces that
are like OK Glass or OK Google
and we're able to deliver
stuff to them that could
be your content.
So with that sort of background,
I'm going to turn
it over to Paul who is going to
give you much more specific
information and ideas about how
you can add more markup,
make better connections between
Google and your sites
to help your content.
It's the right people
at the right time
in the right context.
PAUL LINDNER: Thanks, Chris.
Thanks for that really inspiring
explanation of why
this really matters.
And by the way, you're also much
more than just the same
name as an actor.
CHRIS MESSINA: No.
PAUL LINDNER: This is
the guy who actually
brought us the hashtag.
CHRIS MESSINA: I'm sorry,
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
PAUL LINDNER: For good or
for bad, it's his fault.
But anyway, I'm an engineer
on the Google+ platform.
I really care about
content and tools.
And every day when I get up in
the morning, I think of these
three things.
Number one is, how can I make
tools that make your job
easier and make it easier for
publishers to do cool things?
How can we make tools and
systems that are meaningful?
That deliver value to you, the
publisher, but also to your
users and Google's users?
And also, the one final thing--
and this is something
Chris cares about a lot, too
being a designer-- is, we want
you to really look
good on Google.
And the reason is that
you have the content.
You have users and consumers
of content.
And a lot of times, people
find it on Google for the
first time.
This is where they come
to discover it.
And we want to make sure that
you make a really good first
impression.
We want to make sure that your
content is going to shine.
So now I'm going to go back to
1998, I guess, which is when
Google came out.
Back then, websites were
a little simpler.
We're going to look at something
where content didn't
really shine.
So, back in 1998, your website
might have looked
a little like this.
Well, maybe if you were in
the garage making it.
But back then, HTML tags
were uppercase.
The blink tag was considered
maybe kind of a cool idea, and
frames were just sort of there
from the beginning.
So we're going to actually try
and make this site look good.
Because your first impression
that users see might actually
kind of look like this if you
don't do the right stuff.
So let's jump right in.
So the first thing that we did
it on the Google+ platform was
to offer a way for users
to recommend content.
And the way that they do
that is the +1 button.
So the +1 button is really kind
of the first place you
want to start.
It's sort of the first
place we started.
Let's actually look at adding
it to our nice little pretty
site-- well, maybe
not so pretty.
So to do that--
and how many people here have
actually added a +1 button to
their site?
A lot.
So most people you can just
sort of ignore this part.
But, anyway, just
keep with me.
It's actually really useful.
You'll find a few tips.
But the first example here you
can see is our +1 JavaScript.
And back in 1998 JavaScript--
was it even there?
Anyway, it was kind
of a novelty.
But now it really powers
our entire platform.
And once you have Google's
JavaScript in your page then
there's all kinds of interesting
things that are
going to happen.
So the easy way is you could do
something like the piece of
script above, where you
actually just add a
line to your head.
We'd actually prefer if you
use the second example.
Why?
Because it's an asynchronous
loading of the JavaScript.
Basically, we don't want
to get in the way of
users seeing your site.
We just want to get in there
in the background, and then
enhance it after there
is interactive stuff.
CHRIS MESSINA: To be
clear, these are
two different options.
PAUL LINDNER: Yeah.
CHRIS MESSINA: I can
choose one or the
other, but not both.
PAUL LINDNER: Right.
CHRIS MESSINA: OK.
PAUL LINDNER: So we've added
that to your site, we've
unlocked the potential, so
let's add that +1 button.
[SQUEAKING NOISE]
PAUL LINDNER: Now we have
a black screen.
So let's just suffice to say
that you can add a +1 button
to your site and it will be
very, very easy with a div tag
on your site.
So, we're having some technical
difficulties but
we'll just skip right ahead.
So once you have the +1 button
on your site and users are
starting to click on it,
you're going to see
that count go up.
And when users visit your site
and they actually see popular
content, that's a big
draw for them.
That's a signal that there's
something going on here.
And if you use the form of the
+1 button with annotations,
you may even see that their
friends have been there.
But we want to make sure that
your +1's are going to count.
So what does that mean?
Our little demo site, we
actually have a problem here.
We have two URLs because
people were misspelling
viewsorcerers, with
a u versus an a.
So can anyone tell me what
the difference is
between these two URLs?
CHRIS MESSINA: The u?
PAUL LINDNER: A u.
CHRIS MESSINA: A u.
PAUL LINDNER: But also 21 +1s.
So the count should really be
39, but instead we have a
count of nine and
a count of 30.
And I just want to really
stress the importance of
proper URL management.
When Chris mentioned things like
the names of things on
the internet, well, URLs
are the names of
things on the internet.
And there's a relatively simple
thing you can do, which
is add a rel=canonical tag to
the head of your documents.
And then you can see in this
example that we've said that
this page, this document,
should be at this URL.
And that will ensure
that the count is
properly added together.
CHRIS MESSINA: So what you're
saying is if I have two URLs
for the same content but this
rel=canonical thing doesn't
exist, I won't get full credit
with Google or with my readers
in terms of these counts.
PAUL LINDNER: Exactly.
That would be the one really
good tip that you could take
away with you from this talk
is make sure that your +1's
are going to count.
Because when users actually
interact with that content,
maybe by taking the URL and in
the address bar and pasting it
into Google+, that
counts as well.
When people +1 it in the stream,
when they comment on
it, that counts too.
So getting this right is key
to making sure that you get
all the credit.
It's the page.
It's the URL of the page.
And we can go over this
in questions.
There might be a typo
in this slide.
We apologize for that.
So let's move right on.
Let's talk about the stream
in this case.
When you've actually typed the
URL and shared it, your user
sees something like this.
Chris, can you tell me what's
wrong with this?
CHRIS MESSINA: It looks awful.
That's not what my website
looks like.
PAUL LINDNER: No.
So this is the first impression
that some
people might see.
If you have various images on
your site and then text, be
Google does a very good job of
trying to figure out what your
site is about and the
content there.
But oftentimes you can help it
out a hell of a lot better.
Because in this case, we don't
want the spinning image GIF.
We want the actual title.
So let's look at what it could
really look like if we put a
little effort into it.
In this case, we actually
have a much better
share into the stream.
We have a title, we've
got an image.
So what are we looking
for here?
We want to maximize the
amount of pixels.
So when you're looking at that
new beautiful showroom
experience, you're going to get
125 pixels across to fill.
If you make a nice square image
with that size, you're
going to get a much better
item in the stream.
And you probably also want to
consider doubling that,
because you're going to get a
much nicer look on that brand
new Chromebook Pixel that you're
going to get, or other
high definition devices.
And at the same time, you also
want to maximize the title
because the titles are
going to be popping
out much more now.
So include something really
relevant for that.
how do you do this?
Well, it's actually
quite easy.
Google supports schema.org.
And it's a standard that's
been around for a while.
But it helps you tell
Google what is
important in your page.
So in this case we've tagged the
existing HTML with a name
and an image that we want
to use for sharing.
We can also add a description.
There's other things too.
That's a very simple
schema.org example.
Let's look at something that's
a little bit more complex.
In this case schema.org can
actually represent something
very complex.
It's a music album which
actually has a number of
different properties.
You have tracks.
You have a musical group.
You've got a recording.
All of these entities can be
represented in schema.org.
that looks a little complex,
don't you think?
CHRIS MESSINA: Yeah.
PAUL LINDNER: Chris says yes.
Remember at the beginning--
I really want to help make
it easy for you.
So Google actually has a tool
that's called the Structured
Data Testing Tool found at
the URL you see below.
And this tool will help
you verify that
you've got it right.
You can put in the URL of your
site or any HTML that you
might be editing at the time.
Just cut and paste
and preview it.
So now that you've got some
tools that we can use, let's
look at how we can actually make
your site even better.
How many people here saw
Vic's demo at the
keynote here with relateds.
Yeah?
That was pretty cool, huh?
Now, the great thing about
relateds is it's another way
that users can get
to your content.
And it's done via hash tags.
I think you kind of
like those, right?
CHRIS MESSINA: I do.
PAUL LINDNER: He does.
but the question is it's based
on the content of the page and
the post, so what can we do to
actually influence them?
Well you can.
And again, we're going to go
back to schema.org to do it.
Here is an example
of how to do it.
The main things you need to take
away from this are you
need to choose a schema.org type
that is of creative work,
because it has an
about property.
The about property can tell you
that this document, this
entity, is about
another entity.
And there's a new tag that's
just been announced and it's
actually still in progress a
little bit in the W3C working
group but it's called sameAs.
And in this case we have a
couple of examples of linking
this content to a different
entity.
So the way you do that
is by using a URL.
And It could be any URL.
It could be a Wikipedia URL.
it could be a IMDB URL,
if it's a movie.
It could be anything
you really want
that's something stable.
But we're going to choose
a Freebase URL.
Is everyone here familiar
with Freebase?
I don't see any hands, so I'm
going to tell you a little bit
about Freebase.
So how many people here know
about knowledge cards?
You've seen them in
search, right?
I'm pretty sure there's
a bunch of nods here.
So Freebase is the database
of entities that is
maintained by Google.
So they have an entry
for pretty much
everything that there is.
Songs music, books, even just
abstract concepts like irony
or public speaking.
So in this case we've chosen
two different URLs.
The Freebase URL above is
a link to electro pop.
It's a topic.
And the second one
is a link to a
specific song on Wikipedia.
So what this means is, when
Google looks at this content
it was able to understand
that this content
is about these topics.
And that is what it uses to
build those amazing hashtags.
And the net benefit for you is
that your content can now be
seen in more places.
CHRIS MESSINA: Let me look for
a little context for this.
When I first started using the
hashtag in 2007, I basically
needed a way to tag
conversations that were going
on on that network, right?
There was no way to do it.
A lot of people wanted us to
create these groups, these
places that people
would go to have
conversations about things.
And I was really lazy.
So I was like, well look.
I've got a phone.
I've got SMS.
I want to be able to label my
content when I'm on the go and
not even have to
think about it.
So you guys go do your thing,
I'll do my thing and I'll just
put this little pound symbol in
front of these words, and
those are my tags
on my content.
That's how I tell you what
this stuff is about.
And everybody thought
I was stupid.
And everybody thought it
looked really bad.
And they were right, but
it didn't matter
because it was so easy.
The thing that's really
interesting about what Paul is
saying is actually twofold.
First, within Google+, to
succeed at the game of
Google+, you need to create
great original content that's
valuable and interesting.
However, if you don't have a
great number of followers on
Google+ yet, one way that you
can actually get those
followers is by producing that
content and tagging it with
stuff that's actually related to
what you're writing about.
That way, people that are
popular, like Paul--
when he shares stuff if someone
clicks on one of those
related hash tags and they're
browsing through all the 15,
16 different posts that are
coming in that happen to be
about that same topic and
you've posted something
similar and it's of interest
and Google thinks that it's
worth popping up, you've already
done the work to help
Google get that content to the
right person who's already
interested and already committed
to that stuff.
So by first of all tagging
your content in
Google+ that helps.
Secondly, by adding this kind
of markup to your web pages
that allows Google to then
take that content that's
flowing through Google flowing
through Google+ and all these
different contexts that Google
touches and again know that
what you mean is that this is
content in this case that's
similar or related to or the
same as some other content.
So when I go, OK, Google, I'd
like to hear a remix of "Like
a G6", Paul's song, my song,
our song has the chance of
actually showing up
in the results.
In whatever format
that may take--
whether it's a related post
whether it's something in
Glass or whether
it's in search.
So that's why this is really
important and really critical
to think about when you're
actually composing your
content and marking
up your pages.
PAUL LINDNER: Thank
you, Chris.
So let's move on from talking
about relating content to
other content to relating
from you, the
publisher, to your users.
Back then you might have
actually had one of
these on your site.
And people might have emailed
you and you might have
emailed them back.
But Google+ now has a much
better way of maintaining
contact with your users.
And that's by creating
a Plus Page.
Plus Pages are available for
most different categories of
entities, whether you're a small
group or a rock band.
Publishers probably fall under
the brand category.
But in any, case you can go and
very quickly create a Plus
page for each of the different
entities that you have.
Once you have a Plus page you
need to really stand out.
And to really stand out you
should definitely use some of
the new features that
have come with
upgraded Google+ profiles.
I think this is a pretty
good interesting Plus
page, don't you think?
CHRIS MESSINA: It's
a good start.
PAUL LINDNER: It's a start.
OK.
So in, any case what makes
a good Plus page?
Well number one is that big
beautiful cover photo.
You really want to make it
pop bigger is better.
Again, focus on the high res.
Focus on the pixels.
You want to make sure that the
bottom 12% looks good too.
Because you're going to see what
it looks like like that,
sort of scrolled down.
Make sure you don't have any
weird overlaps between your
profile photo and
the cover photo.
Don't put a whole bunch of
text on your cover photo.
It might come out looking
not as you expect.
And again the same thing applies
to profile photos.
Make them big.
Make them pretty.
And also just be aware that--
as you can see--
your profile photo is going
to be in a circle in some
contexts and also as a square
in other contexts.
And if you're feeling
really creative, you
can also use animation.
And we've had a couple of Plus
pages that have done some
really crazy stuff.
Just amazed.
So if that's your thing there's
a whole talk that's
going to talk about building
audiences using things like
Plus pages by Amy Walgenbach.
That's tomorrow.
So definitely give that
a try if you are in
that sort of category.
If there's one thing they can
take away from this though is
what I want you to do is
to link your Google+
page to your site.
And that unlocks a number of
features, and I'll go over to
them in just a second.
But if you haven't done
already as part of the
creation process, just go to
your profile as a Plus page
and add it to your
link section.
So once you've done that, once
you've added the link to your
site for your Plus page,
you need to verify it.
And to verify you need to make
the link back to your to your
Google+ profile.
So it's very easy to do.
Just add a section to the head
of your document that contains
your Google+ page.
You can use the testing tool.
The testing tool lets you see
the web is Google Sees It.
And that will tell you if
you've got it right.
And then what happens?
In a day or two, you're going
to get this little check box
next to your Plus page
and your site.
And that tells users that this
is the authoritative Plus page
for that site.
And that's really important
when people are actually
looking through a list of all
the different brands and
categories, they're going to
look for that checkbox.
And it shows up in
many places.
In your profile, in the
stream, in search.
So there's more than one way
to add to that linkage.
And I want to tell you about
something new and that is the
Google+ Badge.
We've had Google+ Badges
for a while but this
badge is much better.
CHRIS MESSINA: Yes.
PAUL LINDNER: Thanks to
people like Chris.
CHRIS MESSINA: Yes.
PAUL LINDNER: It allows you to
do the same type of thing but
also gives users a way to
follow your site and see
information about your Plus
page in your site without
having to go to Google+
at all.
And as we support different
kinds of different kinds.
Which one do you like?
CHRIS MESSINA: The
one on the right.
PAUL LINDNER: One on the right.
OK, great.
Let's do that.
So here's some sample
markup of how that
might actually work.
Just add a small div tag, put
it into your page and the
badge appears.
CHRIS MESSINA: And to be clear,
these are not launched
yet, is that right?
PAUL LINDNER: They're available
only for trusted testers.
But they'll be launching soon.
CHRIS MESSINA: So this
is like new stuff.
PAUL LINDNER: It's new, yes.
It is very new.
Fresh.
So maybe your site is--
that's pretty big, though,
you got to agree.
Maybe you want to actually have
something a little smaller?
So how about this.
This is the Google+
Follow button.
So it allows you to do the
same kinds of things.
Verifying your site, allowing
users to follow you in your
page, with just a very small
amount of pixels.
CHRIS MESSINA: To be clear,
you can only get a Follow
button today by embedding
this much larger badge.
And so we've obviously heard a
bunch of feedback about having
more flexible solutions.
And so you we're putting this
Follow button out in
preview right now.
So there's a lot more
flexibility in terms of where
you can put this badge and
how you can make it look.
PAUL LINDNER: Awesome, thanks.
You've got your follow button.
You've got a badge.
Follow buttons also work
for people, too.
Here's our little
song as well.
It works for both contexts.
It's actually great to put
it on a byline like that.
It just appears right in line.
So people can just follow you.
So speaking of authors, someone
who writes lyrics is
an author, don't you think?
CHRIS MESSINA: Yeah.
For sure.
PAUL LINDNER: Photographers?
CHRIS MESSINA: Yeah.
PAUL LINDNER: Videographers?
CHRIS MESSINA: I mean all these
people are creative.
PAUL LINDNER: They're
creative.
So Google actually has something
for those authors.
And that's called Google+
authorship.
Here's an example of a
search result that
I did it for myself--
well for our little project.
Look at that bottom result.
What do you notice?
CHRIS MESSINA: There's a face.
PAUL LINDNER: There's
a face, yeah.
CHRIS MESSINA: There's a name.
PAUL LINDNER: Yeah.
The numbers of circles.
CHRIS MESSINA: There's
a number of circles.
PAUL LINDNER: Yep.
I think that everyone in the
room will agree that this is a
much more compelling
search result.
And we think every author should
have that opportunity.
So how did this happen?
If you go to my profile you'll
notice that I actually have a
link to my GitHub profile which
is where that content
was hosted.
CHRIS MESSINA: Oh.
PAUL LINDNER: And I also have a
link from my GitHub profile
back to my Google+ profile.
So Google being the very smart
search engine that it is able
to understand that those two
things are related and that my
GitHub content is
authored by me.
But you may say well
you know what?
I don't have profile pages
on my website.
There's got to be something
I can do for that.
Well, we've got you covered.
There's another section of your
profile that is called
the contributor to section.
And that is what your authors
can use to list your website.
And then any content on that
site that is properly marked
up will be attributed to them.
So there's one more step you
need to take to get authorship
and that search results.
You can use the rel=author
tag.
And you just put this on your
site on authored content.
So for example on that little
song page that we had, we
would add rel=author to that.
And there's three ways that I
have up here on the slide.
One is you could put it in
the head of the document.
It's invisible, and
you're done.
Second one is you could use a
Badge or Follow button with
the rel=author tag.
You're done.
And then the third way is if you
actually have the link to
your Google+ page directly, you
can just again add a rel
attribute with the
author value.
And you're done.
So that's one way of getting
some really cool content in
the search.
There might be one other way.
What do you think?
What else appears in
search results?
CHRIS MESSINA: I don't know.
Tell me.
PAUL LINDNER: It is ads.
CHRIS MESSINA: Of course.
PAUL LINDNER: Of course
it's ads.
CHRIS MESSINA: Of course.
PAUL LINDNER: One other thing,
by verifying your Plus page
you get one other benefit
that is really cool.
If you saw the talk earlier
about the platform you may
have seen that we talked a
little bit about you can
actually get 5 to 10% better
results on your ads if you
link them to your
Google+ profile.
CHRIS MESSINA: That's huge.
Now, do I have to pay more to
get the 5 to 10% increase?
PAUL LINDNER: No.
You just have to--
CHRIS MESSINA: So you're saying
if I create great
content and I get people to
follow me and +1 my stuff I'm
going to get 5 to 10% possibly
better results than someone
who doesn't do those things?
PAUL LINDNER: Right.
And you'll also get
this benefit.
Your ads will show up with
your number of followers.
And they'll also include a
link to your profile and
clicks on that link, you
don't have to pay for.
and with Google's new enhanced
campaigns, it's really just a
matter of adding your Plus page
to your ad campaign and
you're done.
And if you really like the
search stuff, I definitely
recommend you check out John
and Ardan's talk-- which is
actually following this-- which
is all about other great
ways of getting into
search results.
So Chris is going to tell us
a little bit about mobile
recommendations.
Which is a new thing that we
just launched on Monday that
is really cool.
CHRIS MESSINA: So the thing
that's important about mobile
recommendations-- and what I'm
going to show you next--
is that this is actually
bringing together all the
techniques that Paul
just described.
So from the rel authorship to
the canonicalization to adding
the badges to adding following
links and +1's, what we want
to do is make it possible for
people who are coming to your
site, who are on mobile, to be
able to find content that
you've produced when they're
most interested and most
compelled to actually find the
next link of what to read.
So the way that this works is
that you go into the Plus page
console, control panel
essentially--
log in as the page owner--
and from here you click
For Your Site.
Basically, these are the
controls that enable you to
take the Google+ experience and
start adding more features
to your site without doing any
extra work besides adding that
layer of JavaScript that
Paul first described.
The first thing that you'll have
to do is of course the
one time set up.
This of course happens one
time as it suggests.
And if you've already got plus
+1 JS on your site you're
almost all set.
But there's one very,
very important thing
that you need to do.
You need to add your publisher
ID so your Plus page ID gets
added as a unique
ID to this call.
The reason why this is really
important is because you want
to get recommendations of your
content when users are seeing
these recommendations.
This is what tells Google what
source of data to use when
presenting those recommendations
to people.
So essentially it's like, hey.
Here's that unique ID
that represents us
in the Google ecosystem.
Start showing those content
recommendations to people who
are visiting and browsing
my site on mobile.
OK.
So once you come back here
you've completed that one time
set up, all you have to
do is turn this on.
There are a couple more details
in here for more
control that you can
look at, which I'm
not going to go into.
But users are essentially able
to get information from the
same author.
So if this is a really
compelling article and you
really like the author and what
they've had to say, Boom.
Recommendations.
More from that author.
You're able to get stuff
related to topics.
Remember like that hashtag stuff
that I talked about?
This stuff happens
in mystical ways.
We will bring this content to
the right people if you tell
us what it's about and you let
us know precisely what people
are probably looking for
when they want to
come see your content.
And of course +1 content.
So for people that are visiting
your site and have
friends that have +1'd that
content, we're able to deliver
those recommendations through
the lens of your friends.
So other people like you, people
that you know, people
that are in your circles who
have +1'd content on that site
are now delivering content
to you through this
recommendation [INAUDIBLE]
as well.
Again, these are all different
ways for getting
content into Google.
Making it more contextual.
Adding the power of Google
and the Google content
network to your site.
And of course, don't forget
to add your hash tags to
everything you do.
Your Cheerios and
your vegetables.
It's really important.
Lastly after I/O, obviously
there's a bunch more content
coming up, but we do recommend
you follow us on Google+
because we're also in this
ecosystem and want to make
sure that our content gets to
you at the right in the right
moment when you're
most interested.
We have a Plus page, Plus
Google Plus Developers
on Google.
We have office hours coming
up and you can
contact us via our profiles.
PAUL LINDNER: Thank you.
So, we have a little time
for Q&A. Thanks.
CHRIS MESSINA: And if you do
have questions please come up
to the mics.
I think this is either
being recorded or
live broadcast or--
PAUL LINDNER: It's recorded.
CHRIS MESSINA: --Martians
are listening somehow.
PAUL LINDNER: And also after
this talk we'll be over at the
Google+ office hours to answer
any further questions you
might have.
Yes, you on the left.
AUDIENCE: Hi, [INAUDIBLE]
from Missoula.
First I want to applaud you guys
for doing a good job with
the rel values and connecting
profiles to sites with the
publisher and author and
me and all that.
It's really good to see Google+
spearhead that and
make that happen for the
broader web community.
My question is the div markup
you showed for the Badge or
the Follow button, that doesn't
work if there's no
JavaScript.
Which happens a lot.
Like if the Wi-Fi is failing
for example and JavaScript
doesn't load.
So my question is, do you guys
have plans to give a a href,
like a hyperlink version, that
will at least my take visitors
to my site, to my Plus profile
even if there's zero
JavaScript loaded or
anything like that?
Because Twitter does that with
their follow button.
And otherwise I'll just
have this empty dead
div with a G+ button.
CHRIS MESSINA: Can
I speak to that?
AUDIENCE: Hoping to see
an upgrade there.
PAUL LINDNER: Yeah.
I'll just say one thing
and then I'll let
Chris take it over.
Yeah, that's a popular
request.
There's actually an issue
on our tracker.
And we take your feedback
very seriously.
CHRIS MESSINA: Yeah.
I would say two things.
First, you actually can get a
Badge which is just a standard
a href image, old school web,
totally works, no JavaScript,
images turned off all
that good stuff.
So that solution does exist.
In the particular case here
where you're embedding this
button, we're absolutely looking
into and thinking
about how we could better
address cases
like email, for example.
But we have nothing to
announce right now.
That's what I've learned to say
in the last three years.
AUDIENCE: I don't want
a separate badge.
I want an a href badge that
get smarter the JavaScript
once it loads.
CHRIS MESSINA: Absolutely.
PAUL LINDNER: Yep.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
CHRIS MESSINA: Thank you.
PAUL LINDNER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey guys, a
quick question for
authorship for SEO value.
Right now I'm seeing that it
runs out and you can implement
and it can show up in a week,
it can show up in
a month, two months.
When's it going to roll
out at a faster rate?
And then the other part of that
question, when's it going
to roll out globally?
There's a lot of SEO value in
that for a lot of millions and
billions of dollars.
PAUL LINDNER: Yes,
I understand.
Authorship is becoming actually
quite popular--
CHRIS MESSINA: For
good reason.
PAUL LINDNER: --for search
engine optimization.
Because if you can make the
content more relevant to the
people, then it's much
more valuable.
To each of your questions--
So when's it going to
roll out globally?
I don't know yet.
The authorship team continues
to make great strides in
making it more and
more useful.
And then the first
question was--
you remember?
CHRIS MESSINA: Globally
versus speed.
PAUL LINDNER: Globally
Oh yeah, the speed.
So they've done a couple
of things recently.
One is that if you've registered
for authorship by
using your email address, you'll
actually get an email
when it's been turned on.
There's an alternate form of
authorship that relies on your
email address as well.
So if you go to
plus.google.com/authorship and
sign up with that, that will at
least alert you to the fact
when it's going to happen.
And I'll take your concerns back
to the authorship team
and let them know that
you're impatient.
I know we're all impatient with
these kinds of things
because they're really cool.
AUDIENCE: So this is semi
related at best, I suppose.
I've been a great follower a
proponent of the whole Google+
vanity URL thing.
And every time I speak to
anybody, and I do speak to a
lot of Googlers, it's
like we don't know.
They're trying to automate it.
So I'm just kind of wondering
what's the overall scope and
sort of scheduling for giving
the vanity URLs a little bit
more efficiently and
effectively.
PAUL LINDNER: OK.
So the vanity URL process.
Google+ does support
vanity URLS.
but they're not like
other vanity URLs
you've probably seen.
Basically vanity URLs are given
to profiles that have
significant traffic
and followers.
So it's a process that
is not quite the
same as you're expecting.
So you can't just say please
give me a vanity URL.
It's an automated algorithmic
process like a lot of the
mysteries of Google.
But the main thing you can keep
doing is engage with your
audience and build your
following and the vanity URL
option is then maybe possible.
There's also a web form to fill
out that you can use to
request it.
So again nothing new on
that front right now.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: On the sameAs for the
schema, It seemed like it
would be really helpful, but
on the other hand it seemed
like a spammer's delight.
So I would just tag everything
under the sun and just try to
show up everywhere.
How are you going to prevent
that from being abused?
PAUL LINDNER: So
really sameAs--
so the question is what is to
stop people from spamming it
and just totally blowing
up the hashtags?
Well the one thing is
it's a suggestion.
And as anyone knows with people
using links in Google--
CHRIS MESSINA: Metatags.
PAUL LINDNER: Yeah, metatags
or any number of things.
So Google is quite good at
figuring out if the content on
the site is actually somewhat
related or if it's something
wildly divergent.
So we're going to continue to
use our techniques in this
space just like to use it
with regular links.
The main thing is that if you do
it well you'll see results.
And then hopefully our
algorithms will do a good job.
And I think they will.
AUDIENCE: On one other
separate question.
The--
I don't know what you call them,
data cards or whatever,
in the search and you
end up with--
CHRIS MESSINA: Knowledge
cards.
AUDIENCE: Knowledge cards
on the right.
Trey here is quite popular
on Google+, but we don't
get that data card.
Everything's circled around his
individual profile page.
We don't have a business page.
Is a business page required to
get the data card or the
profile card?
CHRIS MESSINA: I think there's a
couple different answers and
you can probably add
more context.
It again falls back to the
Google magical approach where
it's based on a lot of
different things.
Oftentimes it's based on actual
queries what people are
searching for in terms of
what shows up there.
And for individuals we will
source data from the profile.
In other cases there's stuff in
the Knowledge Graph and so
that's where that comes from.
so it's a little bit of magical
mystery meat that is
what is produced there.
Even though it tastes
delicious.
AUDIENCE: So it's not
specifically like a business
profile gets it and a
person [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS MESSINA: No.
AUDIENCE: But maybe we could
come afterwards?
Because we'd like a few tips.
Because it would seem to me
like his might work nearly
100% of the time.
CHRIS MESSINA: We
can talk after.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, for sure.
PAUL LINDNER: There's a lot
of complexities involved.
But definitely profiles are
supported as knowledge panels.
Certainly.
Just search for Britney
Spears.
CHRIS MESSINA: Alright, looks
like we're out of time.
You want to get yours
in quickly, Danny?
DANNY: [LAUGHS]
I've got like five.
CHRIS MESSINA: [LAUGHS]
DANNY: If I redirect you're
going to count all this shares
in the previous URL
to the new one?
PAUL LINDNER: OK, so this is
about the canonicalization.
DANNY: Kind of.
Kind of.
PAUL LINDNER: So we told
you use rel=canonical.
And that is the best way.
We have other ways.
They may not be as
explicit or easy.
But we generally do detect
redirects as well.
And we may be able to make sure
that your old content
gets there.
It may not happen overnight,
because it's a gradual process
as we re crawl the web, we look
for things like redirects.
We look for things like meta
refreshes and other markup
that tells you that this page
is that other page.
So there's a number of
techniques used.
But over time you should see
that if you do rename your
site for example.
DANNY: Say you have a page, it's
an old page and it's got
500 +1's on it.
And for some reason
you need to rename
the URL of that page.
Typically you would redirect to
where it was going to go.
It sounds like you're
saying that the--
I mean, I don't see how the
canonical's going to
help you with that.
PAUL LINDNER: OK.
If you have two different pages
that you serve up on two
different URLs and they're
really the same thing, use
rel=canonical.
DANNY: Right.
PAUL LINDNER: There's a whole
bunch of articles in Webmaster
Tools and I'm also happy
to talk to you
later on about this.
But the other thing I'll just
stress is that if you're
moving websites, at least
redirect the old site to the
new site and that at
least gives us some
information to go on.
OK thanks everyone.
CHRIS MESSINA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]